450 exposants présents au salon du livre
et de la presse jeunesse le plus grand
d'europe consacré à cette littérature et
parmi eux rue du monde
la maison d'édition évinoise vient tous
les ans mettre en avant ses nouveautés
cette année elles sont particulièrement
centrée sur les droits des enfants et
l'environnement c'est le roi de la
planète
parce qu'aussi maintenant le monde
publie beaucoup de livres sur l'écologie
bah ça devient de plus en plus urgent et
c'est aussi important de sensibiliser
les enfants à la beauté de la planète et
à leur droit d'avoir une planète je
reste un peu un pacte si c'est possible
ou sous sol du salon en fait l'éloge de
la lenteur la thématique de cette 35e
édition issime à la saft rome une autre
issue et d'oise édité par maison du
monde apprend à cette classe d'une école
de bobigny à dessiner des motifs dans
les illustrations que je fais en tout
cas ses albums là qui sont proposés je
n'utilise pas de couleur donc ce qui est
assez peu courant quand on parle de
l'album jeunesse mais par contre je
représente la couleur à travers des
motifs et donc j'ai essayé de leur
expliquer comment moi je travaillais et
là je leur propose des motifs et comment
on peut représenter les couleurs
il fallait reproduire les femmes qu'on
faisait j'ai choisi des vagues du
triangle déclaré à la fin de les enfants
se laissent aller leur imagination rue
du monde de son côté est présent au
stand f2 jusqu'à la fin du salon
temps forts le lundi 2 décembre à 13h30
avec une rencontre débat sur
l'environnement